Book Festival from Washington DC up next
David marinus associate editor at The
Washington Post and author of when pride
still mattered and they marched into
sunlight he discusses his latest Rome
1960 which recounts the Rome Summer
Olympics of 1960
once again on Allen Cooperman senior
editor Washington Post book world and I
am delighted to introduce my illustrious
colleague and friend David Maris as the
son of a newspaperman and grandson of a
printer and David has long suspected
that the hot liquid running in his veins
is not blood but ink he's been a
reporter and writer all of his adult
life including the last three decades at
the Washington Post where I can tell you
he is a beloved as well as admired
figure in the newsroom he won a Pulitzer
Prize for his reporting on candidate
Bill Clinton in 1992 and he recently
edited another Pulitzer prize-winning
series of stories you might have seen
about the wolf full treatment of combat
veterans at Walter Reed Medical Center
his extraordinary books include that
Clinton biography that came out of his
reporting first in his class
also when Pride still mattered a life of
Vince Lombardi
David is a Wisconsinite and a Green Bay
Packers fan also they marched into
sunlight Clemente the passion and grace
of baseball's last year and most
recently Rome 1960 the Olympics that
changed the world ladies and gentlemen
please welcome David Maris
Thank You Alan and thank all of you for
coming here
warms any author's heart to see a crowd
like this my writing pal Rick Atkinson
and I have a code we use when we're
going out on book tours and it's called
the Mendoza line in baseball the worst
hitter in the National League was Mario
Mendoza in the 1970s and if you batted
below him you were below the Mendoza
line and if you go out in a book tour
there are fewer than 12 people in the
audience you're below the Mendoza line
so we're getting like Rod Carew or Joe
DiMaggio here today this is great thank
you so much I've been sort of on this is
the culmination of a long book tour the
started way before the the Beijing
Olympics and because of the nature of
this book which combines truly
everything that I love and have devoted
my career to which is history politics
sports and race this book combines all
of those in a way that took me to some
very odd places ranging from the Chicago
Council of Foreign Affairs to the
lowliest sports jock talk show where two
guys were interviewing me and one of
them said man this is the best book I've
ever read and the other guy said well of
course it's the only book you've ever
read
I got into this book by accident I was
researching my last book on Roberto
Clemente for those of you don't know the
brilliant right fielder for the
Pittsburgh Pirates who died tragically
in a in a plane crash on New Year's Eve
1972 as he was delivering humanitarian
aid to Nicaragua after an earthquake
there truly an extraordinary figure who
transcended sports that rare athlete who
was growing as human being as his
talents were diminishing his first great
year was 1960 and as I was researching
that year when the his Pittsburgh
Pirates won the National League pennant
and then the World Series against the
Yankees I was looking at old sports
sections in August and September of that
year and kept coming across these
amazing names Wilma Rudolph Cash's play
Rafer Johnson Oscar Robertson and Jerry
West a bevy makyla all really immortals
in the world of sports but my feeling
was as I was doing that book that I
wasn't particularly eager to write
another quote-unquote sports book it's
not that I look down at sports in any
way I actually think that because my my
writing world goes back and forth so
much between politics and sports that
politics can absolutely be as trivial as
sports and sports could be as meaningful
as politics it depends on what's going
on and how you look at it there in any
case because I was doing Clemente I
wasn't sure that I wanted to do another
sports book hotel I really took a closer
look at 1960 and those very months when
the Olympics in Rome were staged it was
truly an amazing point of transformation
in the world I was right in the heat of
the Cold War before those Olympics were
staged in Moscow there was a spy trial
where an American pilot named Gary
Powers was
victim espionage after his u2 we
connaissance plane had been shot down
over Soviet territory before the
Olympics ended Nikita Khrushchev the
leader of the Soviet Union left Moscow
and set sail for New York for his famous
appearance at the United Nations where
he founded his fists and railed against
the West those two things bracketed
these Olympics and wherever you looked
across the world the Cold War was
playing out in the world was being
transformed these were the first
televised Olympics for all of you who
watched NBC and Beijing in August NBC
said 2,900 employees to Beijing the
first televised Summer Olympics in Rome
fewer than 50 people went for CBS News
there wasn't even CBS Sports then there
was no sports department NBC paid over a
billion dollars for the rights to the
Beijing Games CBS in 1960 paid fewer
than a half million dollars for those
rights there were 1,200 hours of
television on the NBC networks this year
in another 2,200 on the web in 1960
those first games 21 hours total and
most of all it was right before the era
of transatlantic satellite broadcasts so
to cover the Rome Games the CBS crew
would literally put their videotape and
films in canisters in the belly of
commercial jets and fly them back from
Champa no Airport in Rome to Idlewild
Airport in New York City or they would
be ferried over to a studio at Grand
Central Station and there in the studio
in the editing room in the darkness sat
not just some film editors but Jim McKay
the Jim McKay who became the face and
voice and narrator
our Olympic history later with ABC these
were his first Olympics in 1960 he had
no experience in sports at that point he
was hired for this job
taken from a daytime television show
called the verdict is yours
where he played a courtroom reporter
these were his first Olympics he didn't
even go to Rome he sat in the studio in
New York and as the film would come in
he told me before he died that he would
had a portable typewriter and he tap out
his script on a portable typewriter as
the film was being edited if a country
wanted a gold medal that he didn't know
anything about that country he couldn't
google it he couldn't turn to a hundred
researchers to get the answer to the
questions he told me he literally turned
to the Encyclopedia Britannica that's
where this all started there are so many
firsts in Rome that attracted me to this
story not just the first doping scandal
where a Danish cyclist died during a
road race all of the doping that you've
read about all of the dope testing it
all started in Rome in 1960 not just the
first televised Olympics but so much
more important stuff that has to do with
who we are as human beings
in 1960 the the fight over the Cold War
had a lot of different ramifications
most one of the most important having to
do with race and gender and it's
interesting to think about the Cold War
not just in all the negative terms that
we tend to but in some positive ways the
way it affected the United States here
was the United States presenting itself
as the beacon of Liberty around the
world which it was in so many important
ways but it wasn't in one incredibly
important irrefutable way which had to
do with race the Soviet Union could
found a way how can you call yourself
the beacon of Liberty but so many of
your own people including your greatest
athletes are treated as second-class
citizens
in their home country irrefutable point
as being played out in Africa 14 nations
were getting their independence that
very summer of 1960 and that whole issue
of race was crucial to that this was a
moment when the anti-apartheid movement
in South Africa was just beginning and
leaders of that movement came to Rome to
make their case that South Africa should
either end its segregation or be removed
from the Olympic field because it was
breaking the creed of no discrimination
based on race or nationality or religion
or anything the leader of that movement
Denis Brutus when he wrote his letters
to the president of the IOC Avery
Brundage his offices in Pretoria were
ransacked by the South African internal
police when he tried to get a passport
to come to Rome he was denied a passport
eventually one of his cohorts from Great
Britain did come to Rome to make the
case against South Africa presented it
at a meeting of the International
Olympic Committee also there was the
white leader of the all-white South
African Olympic team who made the
argument that there was no
discrimination going on there were no
blacks on the South African team because
no blacks were good enough athletes to
be on the team this was night this was
the world of 1960 and it wasn't until
four years later that eventually the
world caught up and South Africa was
forced to either integrate or leave the
Olympic movement which it did until
apartheid fell on Nelson Mandela came
many many decades later but there was
also that summer a beautiful thing that
happened the Olympics that had to do
with Africa and race to that moment no
black African it ever won a gold medal
and tell a bevvy Bakula a bevvie Makela
came with a delegation of 12 athletes
from Ethiopia mostly runners a few
cyclists nobody had ever heard of him
before the press
or had his name as makyla a bevvy he
arrived with a pair of running shoes
that didn't fit he threw them away as
the marathon the great ending race of
the Olympics was about to begin on the
Capitoline steps in ancient Rome at
American marathoner named Gordon
McKenzie turned to his teammate after
looking over and seeing this little guy
number 11 all sticks and bones
and no shoes turned to his teammate and
said well there's one guy we're not
gonna have to worry about and nobody did
it tell halfway through the race when
word filtered back that a bevy maquila
was in the lead and it was a truly
amazing scene the marathon was held in
the darkness because of the heat of Rome
it had left ancient Rome and went out
past the outer ring of the city and then
the last 12 miles were run along the old
Appian Way in the darkness with men
dressed as Roman soldiers holding
torches and here came this barefoot
Ethiopian illuminated by the torches
running through Rome the capital city of
the nation that had invaded his homeland
Ethiopia only 25 years earlier under the
fascist Mussolini army and injected
mustard gas into the villages around
Addis Ababa a horrendous moment of
Mussolini trying to establish a colonial
empire and here came this one Ethiopia
and as the Ethiopians would say it took
a million-man army to conquer Ethiopia
and one barefoot Ethiopian to conquer
Rome and here he came back
[Applause]
running through the streets barefoot as
he enters the ancient city walls again
he passes the obelisk of Aksum which was
a work of antiquity from Ethiopia that
Mussolini's army had dismantled and
shipped back and set up as the symbol of
their colonial empire in Rome the
barefoot Ethiopian passes the obelisk
and takes off and he finished at the
arch of Constantine illuminated in the
darkness in the fastest time ever for a
marathon an Olympic history a barefoot
Ethiopian the first ever black African
to win a gold medal the first in that
long illustrious line of West Africans
when we think of distance running now we
think of Kenya and Ethiopia a bevy of
Aquila was the first in the whole milieu
of 1960 America race was an incredible
thing going on there were boycotts of
department stores throughout the
American South that summer protests at
lunch counter sit-ins during the
Olympics themselves there was a race
riot in Jacksonville Florida the United
States presenting itself to the world as
a beacon of Liberty was in an
embarrassing moment how did they deal
with it one of the ways they dealt with
it was through the greatest athlete of
the American team Rafer Johnson Rafer
Johnson was a decathlete from UCLA the
decathlon for those of you don't know is
probably the most trying test of
athletic skill imaginable ten events in
two days everything ranging from
Sprint's to the high jump to the pole
vault to the shotput Raiford Johnson was
such a great athlete probably along with
Jim Brown than a football player and
lacrosse player the two greatest
athletes in in the in ameri
he was also the student body president
at UCLA a terrific person in every
respect with great character bearing and
athletic skills he was the captain of
the United States team and he was chosen
to carry the American flag as the US
delegation walked into the Stadio
Olimpico on August 25th 1960 at historic
moment the first African American ever
to be the flag bearer for the US team in
that summer of tension in the Civil
Rights Movement Rafer Johnson was in a
very difficult situation
he knew that he deserved that honor he
was the greatest athlete he was revered
by all of his teammates and by athletes
around the world only two years earlier
in Moscow at the first ever duel meet
between the Soviets and the American
track and field teams Rafer Johnson had
defeated the great Soviet Vasiliy
Kuznetsov and after the final event at
Lenin Stadium this massive Russian
throng surrounded him at first he was
frightened then they lifted and wasted
him onto their shoulders and carried him
out of Lenin Stadium chanting his name
that's how revered Rafer Johnson was he
deserved the honor of carrying the flag
but he also understood that to a certain
extent he was being exploited 1960
America it's different than 1968 all of
us remember the famous incident of
Mexico City where Tommie Smith and John
Carlos stuck their hands up and a Black
Power salute on the medal stand 1960 was
somewhat different
Rayford Johnson knew that he was being
exploited but also that he deserved the
honor he had to make a tough decision
what do I do
he chose he said to himself I will
behave with the class and dignity and
perseverance that I've always shown and
I'll win the gold medal it was easier
for him to do the first in the second
the gold medal contest
was very difficult because his best
friend
and UCLA teammate CK Yan represented
Taiwan at those Olympics and they were
both terrific athletes
the only reason Taiwan competed in those
Olympics was because of CK the State
Department the United States wanted them
to boycott the Olympics rather than
succumb to the IOC demand that they call
themselves Taiwan rather than the
Republic of China politics is always
going on at the Olympics in every
different fashion it was that as much as
now seek a participant participated
because his country knew that he could
win a medal before the final event of
the 11th of the decathlon it was a
brutal competition they were very close
CK was better at the Sprint's Rafer
Johnson was better at them at the
shotput of the discus it came down to
the last event the metric mile they're
both completely exhausted they'd
expended all of their energy for two
days and nine events Rafer Johnson was
slightly in the lead in total points C
Cain was a better miler all he had to do
was finish by 10 seconds better than
Rafer Johnson in that final event and he
would win the gold medal they had the
same coach the UCLA coach ducky Drake
there was in the Stadio Olimpico over in
the first row of the stands over to the
side before the event Rafer Johnson
walked over to CK I mean to ducky Drake
for some advice CK's a better miler I've
got to win this what what should I do
ducky Drake the coach said while CK is a
better miler but you just have to hang
in there and when the final lap comes to
lab at the bell lab CK is going to turn
around and you have to be right at his
shoulder and you'll break his will rafer
stood okay went back started warming up
CK yang walked over to ducky Drake
for advice what do you suggest coach
you're a better mile or CK ravers going
to try to stick with you but it gets to
the last lap turned around and see where
he is the takeoff you'll break his will
ducky Drake was like a great chess
player playing both sides
Rayford Johnson was not a great miler
but he had one terrific advantage he
knew that this was the last time he
would ever compete in the decathlon and
run the mile and he hated the mile so as
the event started he kept saying to
himself this is the last time I'll ever
have to run this blankety-blank
mile I can't stand it just this one last
time I've got to hang in there never
again this is it I'll go on with my life
I just have to deal with this one more
time
he kept him going they got to the last
lap sure enough CK turned around and
there was Rafer Johnson right at his
shoulder smiling he told me he was
smiling out of pain and acting but it
served its purpose CK tried to take off
couldn't stretch out and Rafer Johnson
finish close enough to win that magical
gold medal and as they reached the
finish line in the dusk and drizzle of
that night in Rome they collapsed in
each other's arms and there's an iconic
photograph of them holding each other up
at that moment these two best friends
who'd adored everything they could as
athletes completely exhausted hugging
each other holding each other up and
it's that really all too seldom seen
moment of what the Olympic ideal should
be in robe with Rafer Johnson ina closed
with one final story which means the
most to me and that has to do with Wilma
Rudolph and the tiger bells of Tennessee
State Wilma Rudolph for those of you
don't know won the hundred meter dash
the 200 or - and that was the anchor
of the relay team in Rome she was the
belle of the Olympics the first
televised Olympics this incredibly
willowy agile runner with a charisma and
grace
everybody in Rome was madly in love with
her John Kennedy the president to be
would later invite her to the White
House and fall off his rocking chair in
the Oval Office he was so smitten by her
Cash's play the young eighteen-year-old
boxer why haven't even talked about who
won a gold medal in Rome was
head-over-heels for Rome for Wilma she
had no time for him
Livio Baroody the great Italian sprinter
told the Oh David if only I could have
gotten alone with Wilma I would have
consummated our platonic relationship
everybody loved Wilma but her story is
greater she was one of 22 children from
Clarksville Tennessee her mother was a
maid her father was a porter of the
railroad when she was young she had
scarlet fever and polio she wore leg
braces for three years
every Friday her mother would take off
work and ride a Greyhound bus with her
from Clarksville down to Nashville to go
to Meharry Medical School the one black
teaching trading hospital in the country
or she would get treatments she overcame
that to become a great basketball player
at Byrd High School in Clarksville and a
sprinter she was recruited to the track
team that won a bronze medal in
Melbourne in 1956 the the relay team at
age fairly 16 she came back to high
school was the heroine of her high
school and got pregnant she was a
teenage mother at age 17 overcame all of
that to win those gold medals in Rome
and become the shining star of those
Olympics and representing not just the
United States but all women thereafter
if there is a Mount Rushmore of women
athletes Wilma Rudolph deserves a place
on that Mount Rushmore and so do all of
her Tiger Belles Tennessee State a small
historically black school and North
Nashville Tennessee
in an era long before title 9 there were
no scholarships for women it was
complete Jim Crow segregation in the
south the coach Edie temple didn't even
have his own office
he had a sharin office with his wife was
the postmistress of the school they had
no transport means of transportation
they'd have to take a clunky old station
wagon to compete against Tuskegee
Institute or Alabama state driving
deeper into the deep south of that era
afraid to stop at night they would pack
peanut butter jelly sandwiches they had
to go to the bathroom the women would
shout from the back of the station wagon
time to hit the fields out of that that
nothingness came the greatest women's
track and field program in history
starting with Wilma Rudolph in 1960
winning more medals than any other place
in the United States truly not
recognized the way they should be not
getting their due until I hope this book
now I'll end with one Wilma Rudolph's
story after the Rome Olympics of course
everybody wanted to see her as I said
John Kennedy invite her to the White
House
and her hometown of Clarksville wanted
to honor her with a banquet and a parade
and barely 20 years old in 1960 America
after all she'd overcome Wilma Rudolph
had the guts to say no not unless the
events are integrated never before
happened that one day and night in
Clarksville Tennessee in 1960 black and
white officials black and white families
sat together in the armory of
Clarksville to honor Wilma Rudolph and
in that one small way she did change the
world thank you very much
I wonder what question over on your
right oh okay got it
how well do you think China fulfills its
promises to let protesters to to let the
Olympics be open compared to what they
actually did and how how could america
influence them to follow through on
their promises
you know before those Olympics started I
said that would be the story of those
Olympics how China handled it handled
its pollution and all the too bad out of
the whole human rights issues and it was
really China's coming out or introducing
itself to the world for the 21st century
which it thinks will be it century and
very well might be it's got a long long
ways to go and there were some early
really bad signs at those Olympics
particularly when journalists around the
world got there and discovered there
were certain things on the web that they
couldn't get and there was obviously
tamping down of certain places we don't
really know and probably won't know for
a year to what they really did to
control the entire environment but as a
journalist you know you spend your whole
life as a journalist thinking my dad was
a newspaperman and and the motto of his
newspaper in Madison Wisconsin was let
the people have the truth and the
freedom to discuss it and all will go
well as a journalist our ethic always is
that sunshine never hurts it always
helps and in that sense there's a belief
perhaps not even sometimes and whenever
you let the whole world into a place
it's got to be for the better somehow
and I'd like to believe that eventually
about places like China
sounds like a Pulitzer Prize story
opportunity
when a place like Rome has historically
been the center of the world or you know
the seat of a Empire you think that
affects the people and the place and I
mean you think had an effect on the 1968
Olympics felt Rome definitely the milieu
of Rome had an enormous effect on those
Olympics the whole Olympic movement was
built around the idea of Athens and Rome
to bear the Baron de Coubertin the
inventor of the modern Olympic Games
those games
always wanted them in Rome but there was
so you had the beauty of that ancient
Rome the gymnastics and wrestling were
held in the ancient ruins there's also
the modern Rome some beautiful buildings
built for those Olympics and then there
was the fascist rule of Mussolini which
was still there when I went to the the
assembly hall where the Italian Olympic
Committee would meet every morning to
plan that day's events the two side
walls in 1960 were covered by green felt
but when I got there the felt had
finally been taken off and there were
these incredible awesome frightening
murals called the apotheosis of fascism
with Mussolini in the center and that
element of Rome was also there
but yes Rome in so many ways the beauty
of Rome the the antiquity of Rome and
some of the frightening aspects of
recent history were all evident in 1961
nice question over here can can you tell
us of the people that are still alive
today in your book can you tell us their
reaction to the story and the historical
record that you've set for them well you
know one of the reasons I write none of
the many reasons I write books is to try
to get right into history people have
been written out of history and I can
tell you that on this book tour when I
went to Nashville Tennessee there was a
crowd this big in the public library and
what Rudolf sadly is gone she died of a
brain tumor the 1990s but their old
coach ed temple was there
seven years old and the moment when he
was introduced from the crowd and stood
up and got a standing ovation was the
most meaningful moment of me for this
whole book thank you very much
[Applause]
you're watching the 2008 National Book
Festival from Washington DC we just saw
David marinus associate editor at The
Washington Post discusses book Rome